Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
What's going on.
Guys. This is Rob and we are picking up with the conclusion of dark nights,
death metal, right? We are completely done with this event now. And I feel like.
A little bit of explanation is needed here, right? Because there's a few things.
They go on first and foremost is Diana Prince wonder woman as she exists in her
current form versus the Batman who laughs.
And I've seen a little bit of confusion in the comment section about this and
the, the videos that I've made. So I'm going to clear this up real fast.
Diana is powered by anti-crisis energy and the Batman who laughs is
powered by crisis energy. Now the question is how do these things work?
So crisis and anti crisis energy are in effect.
Allegories is basically all the are, right?
That a crisis energy is the representation of selfishness, right?
The idea of focusing on the present of living in the here and now,
and not really caring about anything else,
Andy crisis energy is tied to the idea of recognizing that memory.
That history is all one significant thing and that the entire history of
superheroes, despite all the crisis events connects them. All right.
So it's almost one of these things where crisis energy is the notion that heroes
have kind of lost themselves in so far as the fact that they're part of this
great big, huge grant, half a street, right?
It's like standing in a room in a house and not knowing there's any other rooms
or refusing to see them we're as anti crisis.
Energy is kind of like we're in this great, big, huge house,
and there's all kinds of history here.
And it's important that we recognize it right now.
They represent two different types of powers.
And the funny thing about this is that selfishness is Scott Snyder puts it
selfishness.
And in really seemingly crisis energy itself at the outset seems to be more
powerful than anti crisis energy. Now it's not Scott Snyder saying that like,
you know,
selfishness is better is simply means to say that if you look at things in the
moment, that appears to be the case,
but the power of anti crisis energy comes and drawing into the past and looking
at the bigger picture itself.
And that's exactly what happens when it comes to Diana and the Batman who laughs
with these guys facing off against each other.
That is just as much of a physical battle as it is a metaphysical battle, right?
In the sense of Batman who laughs does things like he grabs the Titans,
takes away the powers and throws them, you know,
and like with the intention of killing them and then Diana saves them and then
he attacks her while she's distracted.
That kind of a thing like you see that kind of situation going on,
but it's also a metaphysical and this sense that their fight is happening on a
much grander scale.
So literally when he attacks her and basically punches her and sends her fine,
he sends her flying through both time and space to the point that they actually
traveled back to 160 million years ago. It's interesting because even goes,
as far as to say that with this whole scenario going on,
he makes this sort of offhand remark, right.
And says that maybe if folks respect the past this time,
that big rock simply just won't go, boom. Right. And this is,
this is kind of a double meaning and we'll find out what the second meaning of
this is once we get to the end of the story.
But in the moment when he says that he's talking about this idea of earth,
right. That if people respected the past,
that if people had learned from the past that it basically would lead to this
idea that like we wouldn't have the, the world in his current state.
And here's the why that happens right. As we're kind of going through this,
right? You got Wally West fighting, Barry Allen, you've got, uh,
you got Aqua Bambi attacked by his mom. You've got swamping from, uh,
from like the dark multi-verse attacking swamp in a positive multi-verse right.
Got those great, big, huge fight going on. Um,
one of the things that this really kind of hits that here,
the reason why this is important is because when it comes to the heroes,
understanding their past,
it was the writing of DC comics at the time of those crisis events to ensure the
heroes would not really remember their past coming out of the events of prices
on offenders. There were a few heroes who did remember right. Wally West,
for example, remember it because it was by virtue of Barry Allen dying.
And then Wally West being aged up from kid flash into adult flash,
due to the event, the energy from crisis on infinite earths.
Then he became who he was. Right.
So he remembered there were a few other people here and there,
they kind of remember it, but it was really murky and really kind of crazy.
For example,
like Supergirl didn't really get a proper origin that reconciled her existence
after the death of the multi-verse until you got to around like zero hour and
infinite crisis. Right. I mean,
not even like immediately after crisis on infinite earths was that rectified
with hop man.
He was a multi-vessel character that existed and didn't really get an updated
origin until something like four or five years after the first crisis events.
So it was, it was pretty murky and kind of all over the place, leaving out the,
the publishing problems that that DC had at the time,
the long and short is that when the original crisis on infinite earths event
happened, that the heroes, most of them didn't really remember.
I would say something like 99.9, nine, nine, 9%. Right. All,
but maybe like a couple didn't really remember what happened or that the
multi-verse existed or any of that stuff. Right.
You go into infinite crisis and they they're, you know,
the multi-verse comes back,
you go into final crisis and the heroes are basically told the multi-verse came
back. So I was like, okay, but their history, their life,
as they existed before the events of crisis on infinite earths,
that was still lost. They still didn't know about that.
They knew the multi-verse existed at some point in time,
but Superman didn't remember what his life was like back when he was being
published in the stories before the events of crisis on infinite earths,
having essentially limitless power that he didn't really remember any of that
stuff. Right.
You go into the events of flashpoint where Barry Allen tries to save his mom's
life. He basically ends up realizing things go South if he does.
So he just let her die.
And then DC reboots with the new 52 and the heroes lost all their knowledge
about their, their existence before the events of flashpoint yet again. Right.
So they lost knowledge. And then what knowledge they did have they lost again.
Right? So it's kinda nuts. It's, it's one of these things where, uh,
it's it's heroes constantly being written in a way by virtue of,
of DCS publishing standard.
It would seem that they only ever really live in the moment, but what,
what this really kind of points out and the whole status,
and really the whole position of Diana is to eliminate that concept by
destroying the Batman who laughs she would destroy essentially all the memories
that were lost by virtue of the crisis events.
And so while the crisis events will have happened,
crisis on infinite earths took place, infant crisis, final crisis flashpoint,
while all those events still took place.
Instead the heroes lack of knowledge of what their life was before those events
happened would be restored. Right. They would remember everything, right.
And so that's really where, what Diana Prince stands for.
And so as these guys are kind of fighting 70 Batman who lasts stop, sir, right?
So it was like, stop. We need to stop. Like we need to stop fighting. Uh, and,
and, and it's wonder woman just kind of appearing in this almost huge void,
right? And this giant hand comes out of nowhere.
Now the giant hand of the multi-verse is iconic for DC comic book fans, right.
It's been depicted multiple times over the years.
And it's basically the hand that created the multi-verse now for years gone by,
we largely just believed it was the hand of the presence. We largely believed.
It was just the hand of like this nice omnipotent being that you only ever
really see in vertigo comics,
there was responsible for the creation of the entire multi-verse.
And indeed it wasn't really,
until we got to like the DC rebirth landscape with the idea of document Hatton,
and now with Perpetua that we're actually getting a break away from that
ideology, that what we're getting here,
at least what we got with with doomsday clock and, and the events of, uh,
the Washington being rolled in Dr. Manhattan,
all that stuff is that maybe the hand was Dr. Manhattan.
It was fan speculation at best,
but it was the idea that maybe it was document Hatton, but DC revealed no,
it was not Dr. Manhattan. It was the hand of perpetuate, right?
The creator of the multi-verse as we see it now. And so, because of that,
it was one of these,
these kind of bonkers situations where the Batman who laughs is like this was
Propecia was hand write the birth of the multi-verse as it exists.
So going all the way back to when the multi-verse was first created in DC
comics, which seemingly happened before DC started publishing, right. You know,
this, it gets a little crazy at that point,
but when the multi-verse was first created,
the perpetual was the one who made that. Right.
We know that by virtue of everything from Scott Snyder's justice league run all
the way up until now, the perpetual was the one who created the multi-verse.
But what he says is that her species are called the hands, right?
And they're basically on their way here to erase this entire universe because
basically they dare to want more, right.
Unless the Batman who laughs can kill them first, now a little exposition,
right? A little explanation here, the idea behind Perpetua,
for those of you guys who were a little behind here,
the idea behind Perpetua is that she was,
she really just kind of popped up and broke out of the source wall.
And we don't really know why she was confined there.
We just seemingly knew that she was there.
It wasn't until later in justice league that we learned that she was the
original creator of DC's multi-verse that her race called the hands,
basically those who stand above her had tasked her with going into this huge
empty void and just creating a multi-verse. But where she was a crew,
a supposed to create this multi-verse to suit the direction of the hands as they
had given it to her, she instead chose to make it in her own image, right.
That only the strong deserve to survive apex, predators,
different things like that. So she basically defied her mission.
She was told to do a, she chose to do B basically how that works.
Her punishment was that her children, the monitor,
the ante monitor and the world forger stood against her. Right.
They basically fought her off and then informed the hands of what she was doing.
And the hands locked her away in the source wall.
And she was supposed to be there for all eternity that goes into the original
dark nights metal event, or the source wall was destroyed.
And that freed Perpetua and now Perpetua came back and that's where all,
all this stuff is taking place. Right? So that's kind of a rough, real,
really sort of ad hoc timeline of,
of what's going on with everything happening at the moment. But, uh,
that's the hand that you're seeing here is that a Perpetua, but the idea of,
of the, the Batman who laughs is kind of like the hands don't really care,
right? I mean,
there's on such a level of power destroying our universe would be like
destroying aunts on the side of a mountain.
Why does this it's irrelevant to them that it was supposed to serve a particular
purpose. It didn't, uh,
and now they're going to come here and they're going to wipe it all out as you.
And it's one of these things where he says, if you don't believe me,
then look to the future, look to this future where like, I kill you all,
all the superheroes that you have, uh, that you guys ultimately defeat me,
but half your friends are dead and you allow it to be that way, right?
You don't just adjust things or change things, or, you know,
modify things on a whim. You just kind of let things go forward,
look to that future and see what awaits you.
And the reality is the hand show up and kill them anyway. Right?
The hands show up. So no matter what they do,
seemingly the hands will destroy them, right?
The hands will wipe everything out and seemingly the entire multi-verse will be
reborn yet again. And so in, in the understanding and the recognition of that,
the Batman who laughs goes to make his move and saying,
I can wipe out all existence, right?
And you and I can merge our powers together, right.
We can combine our forces together and we can destroy the hands. And, you know,
as payment for your,
your willingness to help me that I will turn the multi-verse into a place of
absolute insanity and madness, but I will spare your world.
I will give you guys a paradise world to live on where everything will be
perfect. You'll always be young. Everything will be happy. Well,
you guys imagined to be this perfect life. I will give that to you.
That will be your reward for helping me all, just take everything else.
And in reality,
it really does seem like something the Batman who lasts would do, right. I mean,
of what use is a singular universe in comparison to an infinitely expanding
multi-verse right. He can just do everything he wants with it forever more.
It's not like it's an itch. You can't scratch. Right.
He's not like Galactus of the DC universe where it's like, I have to learn.
You just, it's not really like that. Right.
It's a promise he can make and a promise he probably would make.
And that would essentially be it. Now,
there are a few other things I do want to draw people's attention to you in
terms of this main fight that's going on here. Uh, you know,
one of the things that happens for example is that the Robin King cuts off the
hand of Batman, right?
And literally Batman loses his black lantern ring in the process.
There is also this dark multi-verse version of Superman whereby in his universe,
his spacecraft was lost on the way to earth and basically consumed,
or at least absorbed the energy of all the stars in the universe. Right?
So he's just wildly powerful and corrupted he's way beyond Superman. 1 million.
If you guys are interested in seeing that we can cover it.
I think it's only like a few pages long. I don't think it's very lengthy.
It's not like a,
like a one-shot where it's like a 20 page origin story or anything like that.
But, you know, it might,
it might be like a three minute long video that we make, but I'll cover it.
If you guys are interested in seeing it,
the reality of this is focusing back on,
on wonder woman and the Batman who laughs really the meat and potatoes of the
story here. That wonder woman ultimately does not acquiesce.
She doesn't give in Russia is kind of like whatever.
And so what she ended up doing is attacking him and sending him forward through
time, all the way to the end of the universe, right? Where,
where the universe and really even the multi-verse will meet its inevitable end.
It's basic heat death. That, that one of the things that,
that kind of exists here. And I don't know,
I can't really speak to whether or not this is true and real-world physics, but,
and comic lore and kind of a comic book. Them.
The idea here is that the multi-verse essentially exploded into existence with a
big bang and much like how a universe will condense down into a big crunch.
The multi-verse would do the same thing, right?
Like by virtue of his gravitational pull all the energy in existence,
it would essentially condense back down into an infinitely small singularity and
then be reborn as a new multi-verse yet again,
that's how it's normally supposed to happen. Uh, nonetheless,
they're basically here at this point where everything is going to end the issue
with this,
is that any real opportunity that Diana has to full on defeat?
The Batman who laughs through any measure of a lengthy fight is basically gone
because the hands have arrived here.
These beings who intend to wipe out the entirety of the multi-verse they're here
now, and things are about to get really bad because again,
they don't really much care about the heroes or any of that stuff.
And so it's one of these things where the Batman who lasts besieged is wonder
woman yet again, right. One last time and is like side with me.
Like if you side with me, we can save everything. Right. But if you don't,
if you destroy me, right,
because as the heroes kind of unify and as the heroes fight together and so on,
then the anti-crisis energy basically becomes more powerful than the crisis
energy. So essentially the tables are kind of turning here, but it's like,
if you, if you decided to wipe me out, right? If at the end of all things,
if you push me in to this death of this multi-verse right,
where every universe has ever existed as kind of condensed down into this point,
then all that will be left is you. And then in turn, the hands will kill you.
The wipe out, you know, they'll go back there,
wipe out your universe and they'll start all over again. Right.
They'll destroy the multi-verse and that'll be the end of it. Right.
They'll just clean slate, everything. So it was kind of nuts because from there,
again,
you kind of switched back to this battle and you get this really amazing moment,
right? With Batman, you get this really, really cool moment where bat,
where Robin King and his forces had basically killed all the members of the bat
family. And so it's kind of like, I mean,
all the members of Robin's Robin King's forces have died as well.
And Batman is the only one left to alive, but it's one of these things where,
because he had the black lantern ring for a while, it takes a little,
it takes a little bit for the effects to kind of die off. And then Robin,
King's just kind of like, you know, like, I mean, because you don't have your,
your black lantern ring anymore, you're basically gonna dive at man.
Like that's essentially yet it's curtains for you home slice. And then that man,
it's kinda like, you know,
I've met a lot of different MES from across the multi-verse.
And the one thing they all seem to have in common is that they would never do
something as obvious as to take a black lantern ring,
their most powerful weapon,
the thing that keeps them alive and just put it on their finger so that if
somebody came along and did the most predictable thing that anybody could do,
which is cut the hand off and remove the ring that they would,
then I would somehow die. Right? He's like, that's not the case.
This is a symbolic thing. He was like,
the black lantern ring is built into me and literally taps his chest.
And then from there activates his ring and that resurrects the entire army of
Robin kink and all the members of the bathroom,
like the whole bat family become black lanterns. It's pretty amazing. Right.
It's pretty bad even Alfred's back. Right. Looking all decrepit and everything.
Right. So Alfred's back, right? Like he's, he's here now. And, uh,
and it's cool. Right? It's, it's pretty awesome.
But it's small little things like that, right.
In terms of this fight between this just, you know,
last son I think is this version of Superman, I think it's called the last son.
Um, and this, in this fight between him where he's just decimating, right.
Has it's not even close. Right. He's just absolutely crushing this guy.
Like it's, it's, it's not even close. I don't know.
People are going to make a point and be like,
actually Rob decimation means to kill one 10th of everything.
You know what we can use, we can break it down to mathematics if you want to.
And then basically illustrate how it is decimation. Uh, but you know,
in this scenario here,
Lex Luther pops out of nowhere and basically tells like Superman,
get outta here, all destroy this guy. And the question is, how are the,
what are you going to do that intellectually to present a new suit,
this powered by a black hole, right? It's just black hole,
a black hole energy is a singularity.
And the problem with this is that the sumac is like, if you use this suit,
right, this last one is like, if you use the suit,
then you'll create a black hole. Singularity will wipe out the entirety of the,
of the universe where at least the section of the universe you'll start sucking
everything into it. And Lexus like, yeah, that's the point. And he operated,
he activates the self-destruct and creates a black hole event. Right.
And sucks in this Superman, this, this last son, Superman alongside himself,
and basically obliterates everything while that's going on at the very end of
the multi-verse wonder, woman's just like the hell with it. Right? She's like,
whatever, if we're here at the end of all, things that I'm going to go out,
then a very,
at the very least I'm going to go out like the hero I've always been,
I'm not going to go out as some servant of the Batman who laughs governed by
fear. So she grabs this guy and pushes him into the singularity. Right.
Basically destroys the Batman who laughs and she in turn is consumed by it as
well and basically obliterated. Right.
It's she's literally destroyed and that's the end of it. Right? At that point,
she just kind of wakes up. Why should we, we're not really wakes up.
She just kind of per consciousness sort of comes into existence. Right.
And she just sort of looking around, she's sort of, she's basically disembodied,
right? She's like in a theorial form,
but she just kind of like what in the world is going on here? And she's met by,
uh, by another disembodied voice.
And they basically say when we created the multi-verse,
our hope was that life within would follow a path that it would ascend from
simple selfishness to greater truce.
Basically you would become better than what you are and what we've seen in this
multi-verse is it that never happened when its multi-verse was created by
Perpetua? Yes. She bastardized it, Gigi bastardized the whole thing.
But even when she was destroyed and her work was wiped away and a new
multi-verse was created and you were given the opportunity to become better,
you didn't right. You just stayed selfish. You stayed doing crappy things.
You only ever focused on yourself and refuse to accept the fact that there's a
world bigger than you. Right.
That there's more to this world than how you think and feel there are billions
and, and really like billions of people within your own world.
And there's countless live within the multi-verse right.
That that only ever really came down to you. And so, because of that,
this existence that you guys, you know, well, you guys call here, this,
this university you live in this multi-verse that exists is a place of
selfishness, sadness, and horror. And we wanted to wipe it out.
The problem is we can't. And the reason why is because when they beat,
when they basically said,
we're going to take a form to appear to you as what we see as being our,
you know, the, the definitive standard on what a true hero is,
they take the form of wonder woman.
Now it doesn't mean that wonder woman is the end all be all what every superhero
needs to be. It's the idea of what superheroes are. What,
what superheroes stand for that? When these, these guys,
when the hands are talking about the selfish nature of life within the
multi-verse that they're basically talking about non superhero beings, right?
Individuals, the average Joe, you and me, right?
Our inability to look at the world and see more than ourselves. I mean,
and that's, that's true, but even here in the real world, right? Like, you know,
we know that like there are, there, there there's a greater, you know,
there's a greater picture out there and there's other people out there who think
and feel right. That's the definition of a narcissist,
the person who believes that only their feelings, thoughts, and beliefs matter.
And that everybody else is basically irrelevant. Right? That's,
that's a narcissist and most people are not narcissists,
but most people have a tendency to think about things,
but thinking about themselves first and everybody else second. And so,
because of that,
it's one of these things where superheroes were kind of this guiding force that
it was like, Hey,
like we could drag you into the future and we can make you guys recognize that
there's a greater world of themselves. And if you don't want to, well,
then we'll just get rid of you, right?
Like we'll literally create a list of standard on what creates a good person and
anybody who is not part of that list. Then we kill and we just keep the rest.
And the rest of you guys just live in fear, hoping you do not move,
not become one of those people on the list, right? Like, you know,
people who embody those traits on the list, it'd be very dictatorial.
And it essentially the earth three in the DC universe.
But instead superheros exist to guide people into a better future to give them
an example of the standard, to live by,
to fight for things greater than yourself,
to not bend yourself to your most basic needs, to not look at the world,
from the perspective of what do I need, what helps me?
What makes my life better? And instead,
focusing on what makes the lives of other people better, right?
What makes the lives of this world that we live in better and that kind of going
forward from there. And that's how the hands see superheroes.
They see them as being people who were capable of doing great things.
And despite the fact that they stumbled and they fell and they screwed up from
time to time in the end, they were doing not very good things,
but they were doing them for the right reasons. Right.
Not everything they did was good. Right. I mean you to do some shady stuff,
mean wonder woman killed Maxwell, Lord and infinite crisis,
like literally broke his neck. I mean, they'd kill people. Hey happens. Yeah.
You can't make an omelet without breaking a few eggs. You know what I mean?
So they did some unsavory things here and there,
but they all did it for the right reason. Or they did it for the,
for the best reasons they possibly could because they were trying to make the
world better facing off against threats that otherwise would have torn the world
and even the universe apart. And so, because of that, what they say is,
you know,
you guys have kind of given us this example of what superheroes are supposed to
be about how your multi-verse was not irredeemable.
It was not beyond being safe.
It was just that it takes a little bit more of a nudge, but you were right.
When you said that, you know, when you were powered by anti-crisis energy,
you were right.
When you said the shortcoming of superheroes and the people in the world is they
don't really understand the fact that they're part of a much bigger tapestry,
not even your superhero friends know that because they've forgotten so much of
their past. And so from there, it kind of goes into,
we are going to effectively fix things, right.
But it's going to require a great sacrifice on your behalf.
It's going to require you to ascend the on your current form and to become
something greater than what you are in essence, DCS, rebooting,
not really a hard reboot,
but DC's basically reworking the entirety of everything. It's a soft reboot.
It's their, their, their secret war. She doesn't have 15. Right.
But it is in effect. A reboot is basically, I mean,
we can just treat it this way. It's more or less what it is.
It's one of these things where you kind of,
you end up having like this Raby huge celebration, but you know, it's great.
A huge celebration. This, this big event going on,
all the heroes are kind of celebrating the fact that like they won the war
against the Batman who lasts. They remember it all, which is cool,
but they won the war against the Batman who lasts the day with safe.
They realize they lost wonder woman in the process.
But her sacrifice is the reason why everybody's still survived.
So they honor her quite. It's not like, man, where's wonder woman. Oh,
that's why she's dead. Aw. It's not really like that. You know,
it's not really people laughing about wonder woman die. It's not really,
that's the, that's not really the case. Instead.
They're all just kind of taking stock and celebrating the good things in life.
What is usually what happens after a war takes place? Right? I mean,
I just want to point out here all with you guys. See this.
I want to point out here, you got Batman playing the guitar. You've got a,
you got, what was, what's her name? The black Canary chick. You got her playing,
laying a playing guitar who cares. And then you've got Superman singing.
And then you got Wally West than the drums. I just want to say,
I want to see this band play. I don't really care black and errors there now,
but I want to see this band play, but I want to see this band play some music.
If I were being honest, I would trade out black Canary. Well,
I would trade it off for wonder woman, but she's not here.
Like she's basically dead. If I'm being honest,
I would probably say as a Tauna could rock it out. Right.
She'd be amazing on a rock guitar.
I feel like she would just start playing songs that were sad. And you know,
like, like what does she play?
Like golf or like Lincoln park with their first album, you know,
like I'm still misunderstood by the world. You know,
world didn't understand the other singing sad songs about her life. You know,
nobody understands or anything, but, uh, but nonetheless, you know, it's,
it's cool. It's just these little celebrations, but in the middle of this, uh,
Barry Allie comes to Wally West and says, I need you to come with me.
There's something I need to show you. And what they,
what he does is he takes them to the, to this place in the moon and then says,
I need you to vibrate at a frequency of one 60.4 gigahertz,
which one of those is one of the reasons why that's done is because remember the
universe, the,
the various multi versus out there essentially exists by virtue of tuning,
waltz, tuning forks, right?
In the sense that like they have vibrational frequencies.
So it's like the main DC universe might be at the frequency of SI.
And then like, you know, the earth, the universe might be the frequency of D.
And so in order to access that universe,
you have to vibrate at the proper frequency in order to pass through the
dimensional barriers and get to that place. But the, the, the,
the important thing here is that when that's done,
what you end up basically discovering is that this is a whole new set of events
here, right? There's this kind of like massive space station, uh, that is,
is they call it the next stage of the, the halls of justice and doom. But, uh,
it's essentially a place ran by, by villains, but not really because they're,
they're doing bad stuff because there's some of the smartest people in the
world, the whole project,
at least the launches initially being overseen by Superman and Batman.
But what they basically realized is that the actions of wonder woman and what
comes out of this is colossal.
One of the first things to happen is a source walls gone.
There is no source wall anymore, right?
There's no walls separating the various universities and multi verses that exist
out there in DC comics. It's gone, right?
It seemingly it's completely disappeared.
Not only that there is no singular multi-verse anymore.
Now it's multi versus growing at a,
at a geometric rate by the just infinitely expanding multi versus going on and
on and on and on in terms of like the old powers that existed out there,
dark side, there's no indication that he's there. That basically the,
the actions of wonder woman and kind of recruited the multi-verse is essentially
that the entire old standard of comics of DC comics is effectively gone.
That what this does is it allows the possibilities for superheroes and
supervillains from other universes to merge and crossover at a, at a,
at a constant rate, Harvard is that they want to write,
they call it the infinite frontier,
but it basically means that is a whole new kettle of beans.
Batman visited other bet, a Batman from other universities,
but it's kind of nuts. It's cool.
But what this does is it gives DC the ability to kind of initiate this
colossal publishing initiative, which is awesome.
It expands the DC universe in a way that's never been done before,
because what if, what if over that, like in a single Batman story, right?
Let's say you're reading your Batman number, whatever, you know,
written by who in the hell ever.
And then as a crossover between like Batman and like three different versions of
them from across the universe, every story could feel like a mini event.
And I know that seems at the, you know, on the surface, it's kinda like, ah,
I want to do with a bunch of mini events,
but that in turn takes the idea of big crossover events.
And I would hope puts them on the back burner, right.
DC doesn't really do massive crossover events. Anyway,
they've done a lot more in recent years than they used to,
but it used to be that they never really did great big, huge crossover event.
It's only been because they've been Marvel comics.
Then they started doing huge crossover events relatively consistently, right?
I mean, you can see me a song and a dance about how, you know,
dark nights metal is not a big crossover event,
but just because it doesn't have tie-ins does not mean it's not a crossover
event, right. It basically is. Uh, but, you know, imagine that,
like this was on a, on a much smaller scale, right? So imagine that like,
there's some joker from some alternate reality, who's gone awry, you know,
and like jump to a different universe and committed all kinds of panic and stuff
on that universe.
And so it takes Batman from that universe and Batman from the main DC universe
to team up and stop that version of the joker. Right. It's cool.
It creates all different kinds of possibilities.
And it's one of the things that they say is kind of becoming its own different.
It's its own singular omniverse,
and there's an infinite amount of possibilities that can come out of this,
right? There's no telling what they can publish, what they can create.
And now the other thing that they realize is that there's two centers of the
multi-verse. Now that one of them seems to be themselves.
And the other one is basically what they call the world, right?
They don't really know much about that world.
They don't really know a whole lot about what's going on with it.
So obviously that's going to be some exploration,
but the big takeaway from all this,
the big significance behind all this is that the multi-verse is growing to the
point where it's becoming an omniverse. So we have multiple multi versus now.
Uh, and that there,
there are no barriers anymore between the universes that are out there.
So there's all kinds of publishing possibilities that can be done.
It can go on and on and on and on. This is fantastic, right?
This is absolutely amazing. This is fantastic news,
I think is kind of what DC needed. Because if I'm being honest with you guys,
I think one of the reasons why DC struggles so much, you know,
especially if you guys are keeping track of the news going on with DC comics,
I think one of the reasons why they struggle so much is because their characters
are static. They don't change.
They pretty much are the same character they've been for a long, long,
long time. They don't really evolve. They don't really grow right now.
This would be, this wouldn't necessarily be the worst thing.
If like the DC cinematic universe was successful.
Like Marvel characters are pretty much the exact same.
They don't really change that much. They change a little bit,
but they don't really change a whole lot.
Everything goes back to the status quo.
The Marvel cinematic universe is what makes things more interesting for Marvel
comics. If the MCU didn't exist, Marvel comics will be boring as hell, right?
But it's the compliment of the MCU and kind of seeing the characters in a little
bit of a different light that make things different.
If DC had that in terms of their movie form, it would be the same way,
but they don't buy because nobody knows what's going on.
They don't even know what's going on.
They're like I have this massive plan on how to,
how to make their DC cinematic universe cohesive and work. And, and I,
I don't even know who to take that to, but nonetheless,
or if it is even worth feeling, I have no clue.
But the whole point here is that what you have is a, is a,
is basically a brave new world, right? If out is Huxley was writing this event,
it would look like this. Here's a brave new world.
There's all kinds of possibilities. Right? So with that being said, guys,
we're going, gonna bring this video to an end. If you are new here to comments,
explain to make sure you guys at the sub button to become part of the Rob port.
If you guys enjoyed this video, make sure you drop.
A light and I will catch you all later, Bruce.